[Música]
es que ya son 48 días de guerra en
ucrania y la situación es devastadora a
medida que las fuerzas ucranianas
recuperan el control de varias ciudades
que estuvieron en manos de las tropas
rusas las autoridades de la región de 10
descifran ya en 400 el número de
víctimas mortales entre los ciudadanos
en lucha según evaluaciones de las
matanzas reveladas tras la retirada de
las tropas rusas de esa localidad por su
parte la fiscalía general de ucrania
aseguró que tiene información de que se
están cometiendo o al menos se han
cometido presuntos crímenes de guerra en
alrededor de 6000 lugares en territorio
ucraniano la última situación que se
conoció sobre estos graves hechos fue en
la ciudad de mariupol donde el
regimiento ucrania novasoft denunció las
fuerzas rusas que utilizaron las armas
químicas
denuncia que está siendo estudiada por
las autoridades de reino unido y que ha
sido negada por las tropas separatistas
de dónetsk para eso entonces saludamos a
andrés servín nuestro primer invitado
del día él es doctor en ciencias
políticas y analista internacional
andrés gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente en directo americana de
france 24 muy buen día le preguntó su
balance estos 48 días de guerra en
ucrania
buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación
mi balance en realidad se orienta a
más lo que está reflejando esta guerra
en el contexto internacional yo creo que
es muy importante tener en cuenta que
lo que estamos asistiendo es una
prácticamente una división de la
comunidad internacional a pesar de que
las apariencias no lo indiquen de esta
manera si nosotros seguimos las condenas
a rusia en el ámbito de los ámbitos
multilaterales relacionados con las
naciones unidas vamos a ver que ha ido
creciendo el número de abstenciones o de
respuestas en contra de la condena está
la invasión rusa y esto tiene que ver
con creo que además con una dinámica
económica muy compleja que se está dando
en este momento las sanciones económicas
en sí impuestas por occidente han tenido
un efecto búmeran y eso es muy evidente
en el caso de europa que sigue
dependiendo de los combustibles fósiles
rusos pero también se refleja muy
claramente en cómo
ayer si no me equivoco una reunión entre
el presidente de la jr y el primer
ministro modi de la india para
conversar sobre estos y otros temas y
hubo presiones de eeuu para que india no
siga comprando
combustibles a rusia y lo cierto es que
tanto india como china como otros países
del asia están aprovechando la coyuntura
para conseguir el gas y petróleo y
carbón a buen precio de rusia este y de
esta manera están limando toda
posibilidad de que las sanciones tengan
un efecto drástico sobre la economía
rusa y a esto se agrega la posición rusa
de que en el ámbito financiero ha dicho
que si pagará sus deudas siempre y
cuando lo pueda pagar en rublos dado que
131 mil millones si no me equivoco de
dólares de las reservas rusas están
congeladas en bancos occidentales
entonces yo creo que hay un cuadro muy
complejo que se está jugando en torno
más allá de la información en la
desinformación de ambas partes con
respecto a la guerra en sí en torno a la
guerra y que en realidad está generando
una especie de polarización en el mundo
entre aquellos que sean condenados
firmemente la invasión rusa en ucrania
andrés entonces con lo que usted dijo si
la situación continúa de esta manera y
no hay digamos una unión de toda la
comunidad internacional y de los
clientes de los combustibles fósiles de
rusia estas sanciones que hace occidente
sobre todo la unión europea y eeuu no
van a tener un efecto que ellos quieren
que vladimir putin digamos se siente en
la mesa y haga una negociación para
terminar esta guerra este conflicto
armado en ucrania
sí yo creo que efectivamente si nosotros
juzgamos por las últimas cifras ha
habido un incremento en las reservas
internacionales de rusia en rusia a raíz
de la venta de combustibles fósiles
entonces el efecto de las sanciones en
realidad está impactando negativamente
por un lado como todos bien sabemos la
situación de europa que depende en
particular del gas que proviene de rusia
pero también tiene un efecto negativo
sobre la economía global en general y
llega hasta eeuu en términos de la
inflación que está generando y
posiblemente cómo está afectando la
recesión económica que
se produjo después de la pandemia y
frente a la cual había que desarrollar
toda una serie de políticas que ahora se
ven restringidas por lo tanto yo creo
que a corto y mediano plazo vamos a
tener una situación de recesión o
desaceleración de la economía mundial
ayer también andrés el canciller
austríaco se reunió en moscú con
vladimir putin una reunión donde no se
llegó a nada el pesimismo del canciller
austriaco la vía diplomática que se está
agotando que va a pasar
yo creo que por el momento vamos a
seguir con una intensificación de las
actividades bélicas en ucrania
seguramente en función del nuevo plan
que está desarrollando rusia en el
sentido de asegurar la zona de bombas y
separarla dentro de lo posible
del resto de ucrania y en este sentido
la caída de la ciudad de mariupol es
fundamental y yo creo que vamos estamos
enfrentando la posibilidad de una guerra
prolongada no una guerra que se va a
resolver una inmediato por lo tanto en
el ínterin el desarrollo de canales de
comunicación diplomáticos está bastante
limitado una guerra prolongada que se
centraría entonces ahora en la región
del donbass digamos en el este del país
para terminar de independizar digamos
que esta región del donbass de todo el
resto de ucrania oa lo mejor las tropas
rusas y se van a ir diversificando e ir
al centro más del país
continuando con su asedio que tenían
sobre la capital kiev
y yo no soy un analista militar pero en
mi percepción lo que está pasando es que
rusia está asegurando desplazar con los
desplazamientos de tropa asegurando a la
zona de las bombas y del este de ucrania
y por otro lado esto no implica que no
va a dejar no va a seguir haciendo
desarrollando acciones en el oeste de
ucrania
como para ir desmoralizando a la
población ucraniana en general pero la
concentración de las fuerzas rusas creo
que se va a dar en el este y para
asegurar esa zona en función de los
intereses rusos pues andrés gracias por
su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 analizando
un poco políticamente internacionalmente
estas consecuencias de los 48 días que
lleva la guerra desde que rusia inició
su invasión a ucrania gracias andrés por
su tiempo
muchísimas gracias a ustedes